Theory,
if there were as much matter as there were anti-matter it all just would have
been isolated and we would have had a universe of energy. But again,
it was that one part in a trillion a little bit more
matter, uh, that, that may have explained why we are here today.
So, Peter, yes,
not uncommon these days to hear people describe, uh,
the current state of things as upside down.
I think that's fair to say in the last six months,
a lot of people's lives have been upside down a lot longer than that, but, uh,
everybody's been sort of upside down the last six months.
No doubt about it, but possibly because of that, um,
some news that came out, I believe it was April and, you know,
it was smack dab in the middle of where COVID was really blowing up,
so to speak.
And of course there was a lot of attention on that and you could argue
potentially why this didn't get as much attention as it did.
Yes. And absolutely. And, and to be honest, even within that,
taking that all into account, it may be, did get a relatively,
a lot of coverage,
but there was a story in April that there was an experiment going on through
NASA, up in the Arctic. Um, we'll get into that little later,
but essentially what the results had shown was
potentially evidence that a parallel universe
existed where time went backwards.
And of course that was the juicy headline universe,
parallel universe discovered with where time goes backwards. People are like,
what? But I don't. Yeah. I mean, I think, you know, some people were like, wow,
whatever, but other people were like, wait a sec,
what the hell are you talking about here?
It was matter's evil.
Twin. It was matter's evil twin,
our friend or enemy anti-matter.
Yeah. I remember during the backwards a universe theory. Yeah.
Which again, I mean, interestingly,
the movie tenant is out now where that idea of time going backwards is actually
just not a spoiler people relax. It is it's in the trailer. Um,
but this idea that there could be literally, uh, an opposite universe,
bizarro world, if you will, like in Seinfeld, like in Seinfeld,
like in Superman and it's not something I realized
anti-matter is not something we know very much about.
Do you know who does know a lot about anti-matter.
Our guest today? Of course, Liz Lando, Lando.
Liz Landau is an award-winning journalist and science communicator.
A self-professed lifelong nerd. Liz is interested in astronomy,
particle physics, archeology allergies, math music.
And of course the number PI by Liz holds
a bachelor's degree in anthropology from Princeton university and a master's in
journalism from Columbia university.
Liz spent six years at CNN before joining NASA in 2014.
Liz, welcome to what if discussed?
Oh, it's so great to be here. Thanks so much for having me.
So in the beginning, as Peter and I were talking about off the top,
uh, according to big bang theory,
a lot of energy was created a lot. A lot of matter was created.
A lot of anti-matter was created. And then somehow the matter one out,
we get galaxies and planets and stars and Peter and Richard and Liz,
and kind of,
there's still a pretty big mystery as to what happened to the anti-matter.
And I'm sure I'm butchering this, but that's why you're here. Um,
Kara new positive guests as to what happened,
it could be worth a Nobel prize that maybe you could share with Peter and I.
Right? Yeah. So as you said,
it's kind of like that bare naked lady song that plays at the beginning of the
show, the big bang theory,
our whole universe was in a hot debt state.
Then nearly 14 billion years ago, expansion started weight.
Like that's actually accurate. But in any case,
in those first moments know there was this creation of
equal amounts of matter. And anti-matter, and it is, as you said,
it's such a mystery about why we are all made of matter
today. And in fact,
it would have only taken one in a trillion
of an imbalance,
one part in a trillion more matter than anti-matter,
uh, to give rise to the universe that day.
And what was responsible for that one part in Australia is
still a mystery.
I don't have any particular death of my own,
but the particle physics says that places like CERN and Europe are
really looking at what kind of physical processes could do
rise to an imbalance of matter. And ants matters such as when certain particles.
Math, science, history unraveling the mystery. Yes, ladies and gentlemen,
it all starts with the big bang. Liz.
You can obviously create a lot of energy by splitting an atom,
as we found out by, uh,
creating nuclear power and ultimately nuclear weapons.
How does that stack up with the energy created when matter and anti-matter
collide?
Yeah.
So you might be surprised to know that while we don't see any
anti-matter around us, there actually is a tiny, tiny bit.
And in fact, I brought an anti-matter producer with me.
This is a banana banana,
and any banana really is actually producing a thimble particle of
anti-matter every 75 minutes or so.
That's about how long a banana lasts in my house before it turns black.
And so, uh, that might, so if you got to get it all the bananas of the world,
however,
you still wouldn't have enough anti-matter to produce other
kinds of explosion, but you might see in a scifi show.
Is that, is that because of the potassium in the banana.
That's correct. A potassium 40 is a radioactive isotope,
and that's why every 75 minutes or so it's a single,
an anti electron positron is actually coming out,
but a single particle,
especially a single particle anti-matter will not stay around for a while
because it will immediately meet its evil twin,
a regular electronic, they will not wait. Uh, in fact,
single particles annihilating is really not going to produce any
noticeable effect.
Otherwise we would see flashing lights all the time, right?
I bet our own bodies because you said negligible, but, uh,
AIDS in a mouse of its cutter.
But at any case you really need a gram of
it.
If you had a gram of matter and a gram of anti-matter
that could actually produce the explosion of a nuclear bomb,
however,
we can all take comfort in the fact that it's nearly impossible to
collect a gram of anti-matter because, uh,
these particles are so fleeting, they're annihilating with matter all the time,
and it's very difficult to extract them.
And in fact, very cost, uh, negligible at sailor, I guess,
constantly costly I could have just said opposite. Uh,
cause I mean there's all sorts of numbers floating around as to what it would
cost to create. Anti-matter uh,
I have one milligram of anti-matter would be about a hundred
billion dollars to produce why is creating
anti-matter so expensive.
Yeah. Again,
when you have only single particles of anti-matter being
created naturally and being annihilated in less than a second, you know,
it's very difficult to, uh,
mask them in any appreciable quantity. Um,
it's some of the experiments that they're doing, um, for example,
the alpha experiment at CERN in Switzerland, uh,
they actually have to decelerate these particles and they have to have some
kind of magnetic fields to track them. So you have to have like a,
literally a magnetic trap to get all the anti-matter together to even
really study their properties in any appreciable. And again,
even that experiment is,
is part of this huge nuclear research organization,
stern. And, you know, Sarah also has the large Hadron Collider, uh,
know multi-billion dollar world's largest science experiment, uh,
which also, uh, you know, studies anti-matter. So, uh, yeah,
just because of the tiny,
tiny amount of anti-matter available, uh,
it's so expensive to do anything meaningful with it
scientifically.
Hmm. One of the reasons people have looked into creating anti-matter is to
potentially power spaceships.
Why would anti-matter be effective as an energy source for space exploration?
Yeah. If you could get appreciable amounts of it together, uh, you know, again,
to have that huge explosion of annihilation of
matter and anti-matter together, uh, that could be extremely powerful
as a kilogram of anti-matter and a kilogram of matter if they were
somehow able to come together of that could be like a thousand
atomic bomb. That was, that would be a lot of energy.
Absolutely. Um, but again, because it's so expensive,
it is sort of impossible to do anything like that to harvest the
power of it's matter right now.
Yeah. It would probably be pretty dangerous to have in a spaceship too.
I'm imagining all that power.
Are there any other practical applications of anti matter that we know of?
Yeah, actually it's fairly awesome. In the medical fields we have,
what's called a pet scan that you might've heard of a,
which stands for positron emission tomography.
And this is actually using antsy matter to do
a brain scan noninvasively. Uh,
what they do is they give you a substance that has a radioactive
isotope in it. Uh, it's just like bananas have radioactive potassium 40 up,
you would get a harmless substance that has a radioactive element in it.
And then as that radio isotope decays,
it emits these anti-matter particles that then interact with
your brain again in a fairly harmless way.
Cause there are so few particles in a substantial way such
that you can actually produce a brain scan.
Sort of like a, an MRI on steroids. Yeah.
I guess that that's the type of eloquent, uh, articulate examples.
You get here on what is discussed from Richard and Peter. Um,
so when I hear, you know,
anti-matter explained and it's essentially the mirror opposite of matter,
you know, it rotates at a negative versus a positive. And if you,
if you do a deeper dive, it's essentially, you know, uh,
two matters down black to matters white, that type of thing, which, you know,
kind of sounds like bizarro world Superman or a lot of the other scifi,
Ebony and ivory. Um,
and so that could get someone to wondering,
and that someone of course is me. Um,
it sounds almost like parallel universe theory and
that might've been sort of crazy talk at some point, if we were doing,
what if discussed 10, 20, 30, 40 years ago,
these days was string theory and mult, uh,
and multiple universe theory being more accepted in mainstream physics.
Is this now something that could be the,
sort of the first real ability to, we talked off the top about that?
The news that came out earlier in April about the, you know,
maybe there was evidence or that, you know,
there was a universe that time was going backwards, et cetera,
is anti-matter may be the sort of the window into really understanding that.
Well.
The short answer is we don't know. I mean,
there's really no evidence that's substantial of a parallel universe or
anything, but it is really intriguing,
but every particle we know has an evil twin,
if you were to say something like that. And, uh, you know, if you, uh,
Richard Fineman had a quote about, you know, if you were to meet your, uh,
anti-matter twin on bars, like don't shake hands.
Uh, but yeah, I mean, right now, you know, anti-matter is,
is really most interesting to scientists because it really gives us this,
uh, it's such a fundamental mystery about why we are the way that we are and
really why we exist at all. Because again, in theory,
if there were as much matter as there were anti-matter,
it all just would have annihilated and we'd,
we would have had a universe of energy. Uh, but again,
it was that one part in a trillion that was a
little bit more matter, uh, that,
that may have explained why we are here today. Hmm.
Doesn't sound random to me, but that of course is a story for another,
um, can you stick around Liz? Cause we have plenty more to talk about. Um, we,
we we'll get to that on the other side,
on the extended version of what if discussed the audio, uh, podcast?
Where can people find your work? Oh yeah.
You go to my website,
Liz land out.com or you can follow me on Twitter. Uh,
I am,
co-hosting a podcast called pod paper scissors that you can find on Cod
paper, scissors.com. Uh, for NASA,
I produce a podcast called gravity assist, which is at
nasa.gov/gravity center. Um,
and I also write songs about science that you can find on my YouTube
channel, which is youtube.com/.
We're just riffing off the top there. That was that's.
That's actually one of your many talents is singing improv and
also talking about the solar system, ladies and gentlemen,
that is Liz Landau stick around for more with Liz on the other side.
Where can people find that link, Peter?
Well, if you're watching the YouTube,
you can find it right below the window here. This is it,
this right down here. But if you're listening already on the podcast,
don't go looking for a link. You can't you're wearing headphones.
You're not looking at a screen. There's no link to look for.
Just keep listening. We'll continue with Liz Lando on the other side. Okay.
Thanks Liz. We'll talk to you later in the show.
Fine. Thank you so much. Um.
Lots to talk about after that sort of first half discussion,
clearly anti the people out there right now, making Bitcoins and like.
Yeah. In your basement, like 15 computers and whatever. Oh my God.
Imagine how much they could make. If they had powered their computers with.
Two words for you, auntie matter, get on it. It's basically the new gold.
Oh, you mean you're talking about them finding anti-matter.
I thought you were talking about powering their Bitcoin computers with
anti-matter because those Bitcoin computers use quite a lot of electricity.
So here's the business plan.
You create the anti-matter then you put that anti-matter into powering those
computers. You can make more anti-matter and of course you're rich.
You're a superbill and you have a bond building, but that's another discussion.
No, but in all seriousness, I mean,
it is interesting that you have the top scientist on the planet earth,
who all seem to have a consensus around the idea that at that big bang
origin point, an equal amount of matter anti-matter is created.
We're all, we're all in agreement on. Yeah, no. Yeah. We're all. Okay.
The anti-matter essentially for the most part outside of bananas and some other
folk around disappear.
Yeah. Anybody have any idea where the auntie? Nope. Anybody? Okay.
I have any idea what it means. No, like you don't,
you usually it'll have some rogue people, some scientists out there with some,
you know, some strong theories, but basically matter wins out.
You have the creation of things that we see as solid and anti matter is still a
big question, Mark. And the place again, not surprisingly,
perhaps because it was in the news. So prominently years ago,
when they were looking for the God particle CERN.
They know the place. Well, they can create it. Yes.
But as she's talking about, I mean,
I don't know what the price tag was of CERN to build CERN,
but it's in the billions it's, you know, stories in the, in the underground.
And when, when people were talking about that whole, you know, again,
the search for the God particle the Higgs boson. If people don't know the term,
but you know, some people were asking questions, layman like myself and myself,
wait a sec, let me get this straight here.
You're going to be crashing particles of anti-matter and matter into each other
at close to the speed of light. Now I just here on Wikipedia.
It seems to say, when that happens, they self annihilate and everything.
And it creates some sort of energy level. As Liz talked about,
that's on the scale with atomic bombs. Should I be concerned?
A lot of people thought perhaps we were going to create a black hole. Yeah.
Yes. But we didn't know definitive. Well, you and I.
Sweden the layman as you speak, but the scientists knew,
these knew one particle versus one particle will create an explosion. This big,
you know,
a gram of anti-matter versus a gram of anti-matter will create an explosion.
Big manageable. And it seems again, when you're on the other side of history,
things seem impossible, right? Again, you know, we've talked about it before.
I think it was like late 18 hundreds at the end of the 19th century,
it was considered scientifically impossible for lighter than air
flight, as it was called flying,
I think 1908,
the Wright brothers are flying a plane like less than whatever, 10 years later,
they took something that was completely inconceivable and literally considered
impossible. And then they did it.
We know how that story ended now cut to we're going to the moon. So I.
Mean, you could argue that story has not ended. And absolutely.
And I agree.
Well maybe that's where w where I'm going unconsciously is that you figure out
this anti-matter issue and the energy that's created through that,
and you could harness this. Now we made the wrong,
let's say we made a mistake. You could argue,
some people would say nuclear energy is a massive part of really cleaning up the
world and getting it safer, but also, you know, getting rid of fossil fuels,
other people would say, no,
I think splitting the atom was a mistake because of the ramifications of nuclear
weapons. Do you trust us Peter speech?
And to be able to crack the nut on anti-matter for the pluses,
it could create for the world versus the minuses.
I do. I do, because humanity,
if you're talking about the mistakes made with nuclear,
I think we've realized as a civilization that we've had,
that could have been a mistake in some ways that it's been utilized. Um,
I think going forward people aren't, uh, how maybe they are, I don't know,
maybe I'm thinking they aren't interested in using it as a weapon,
but somebody is someone, but maybe to your point, Blofeld.
No bond villain. There's always a bond villain out there,
but ultimately I think enough people understand that, you know, to your point,
that learning from mistakes, yes, we, we do repeat history and make mistakes,
but if we're able to solve auntie, it's not free energy,
which a lot of people have talked about, you know,
basically taking energy out of essentially the,
the ether and being able to, because there's so much energy and such,
we just haven't been able to.
It's not free energy, free energy you're out until we figured that out.
So again, perhaps a Nobel prize in the future for both Peter and I, well,
I think, I think, I think it would be a shared Nobel prize.
We'll let Liz know if her name is, is included on that.
But I think if we're doing this show in five to 10 years,
there's been a massive amount of progress on the understanding anti-matter and
how to harness energy.
Out of it. I hope. Well, why don't we, uh,
pick it up with Liz land out on the other side,
in the extended audio podcasts. Now there's a link to that.
If you're watching on the YouTube, on the.
Grandmother, if you're watching this on our YouTube,
there's a link to the extended.
Audio portion right below you. Now that's like I say, if you're watching,
if you're listening to the podcast right now, just keep listening.
It just keeps going. You don't have to, you don't have to go anywhere. Yeah.
And you won't be sorry, because we,
I guarantee we're going to get into some super cool stuff with it.
Oh yeah.
We'll talk more about the secrets of anti-matter and how to create it and the
costs involved and what we can do with it.
And there's a whole bunch more stuff to talk about.
So you're going to want to click on that link, my friend, um,
if you don't have enough time and, uh, you gotta go, so be it,
maybe you'll join us next week on what if discussed?
[Inaudible].